[Music]
you know hey I haven't burped its there
it won't come out don't be ashamed of a
barbecue
you just got burp oh yeah well you're
hitting my shoulders no that's not gonna
do it okay there go ahead - or you might
crack her back true I'm very brittle
anyway so it's speaking of brittle ice
is brittle right oh I thought you said
Isis you don't like cuz they're [ __ ]
going down listen I'm talking about ice
like a frozen lake oh yeah that can
crack right yeah don't ice skate there
well I'm skating on thin ice oh yeah
this is no nice Isis on ice all Isis top
players will be skating in the whole
[ __ ] thing gets blown up immediately
cold I'll buy that merch for sure
I blame mercury retrograde okay Jason
Clark he has about 400 and 400 thousand
followers on tick-tock and he created
this tick-tock where he's swimming under
ice but I'm buddy is getting ice punch
ow no no he almost died that's awesome
he got stuck well he couldn't find his
way out I knew it you couldn't find a
breathing hole well maybe because it
looks like water all right let me tell
what happens yeah yeah let me tell us
why he created a hole in this end right
he goes in I'll show you the video he
goes in he created another hole and
listen he was supposed to do a straight
shot but then once he got under he says
that his eyes froze where he couldn't
see and then so like he ended up like
trying to find his way he's like why
didn't you turn well and then he tried
you turning but he couldn't find it
because he was trying to find like or go
with the path of the the dirt that got
picked up and
it ended up like he's still couldn't
find it so then he turned one more time
you turned again you don't do that time
no but that saved him cuz he was like
he's like just one more second I would
have died
he couldn't like his entire eyeballs are
like frozen and think it through huh oh
this was so stupid man
well that's biggest stupidity no it's
called Jason to-do list and so he does a
lot of these like bucket list things so
that's one of his bucket list things is
to like swim under like a hook more
holes next time that's a bucket listing
walk his bucket list yeah
how about have sex with my wife at car
yeah sure the real Iceman you mean like
on the roof outside while it's moving
right inside the car like I've seen this
yes they went viral there's a bomb to it
thank you yeah it does not look cold it
all got this his girlfriend's recording
oh she didn't even chance oh that's a
lot a lot of people are saying that but
she don't know how to swim I know we're
just idiots we're just commenting when
we don't have [ __ ] so I wanted to kiss
he in the back of his head why does he
wear goggles no he was explaining to
another hole oh my god it's too far to
pray why did you go all Northey I saw
the hole it was right there you have a
huge effect [ __ ] I don't know it is I
can't see it's cold I would have died
already I would have died already I
would've died he's just touching live oh
I would have died that's okay they need
a better product oh my god
No so the thing is I keep praised a lot
so she thought that it was another one
it was like free he could also hold his
breath for over three minutes oh he
threw wim hof [ __ ] got plenty of time
yeah so she thought he was okay okay it
looked okay holy look at that dog the
dog is clueless - the dog is like the
way like he's like god damn where the
[ __ ] is a [ __ ] yeah can we try to play
that back and all of us hold our breath
that's what I do this now while moving
though 42nd thirty-second you wanna do
it yeah I could do 47 you gotta do it
while moving that's the hard part
oh yeah alright ready ready wait you got
to play okay we got to see me honestly I
don't breathe there you're not [ __ ]
liar I'm gonna do it fine you caught me
I could do it no [ __ ] no more
[Music]
we took a little bit in there when you
said expert lung capacity as a diver
[ __ ] breath for a man in the half Wow
but I lost it in 30 seconds yeah why
running like crazy when you're moving is
different what use moving more
accurately I think we weren't using our
legs really yeah but at the same time
China's smoker thank you huge we eat and
everything guys a shocking thing of a
story in addition this dick shrivel up
big-time oh man yes that really did was
balls anyway I ended up doing it for a
second time but this time he does any no
no no yeah goggles or something okay so
he added more safety precautions which
is adding goggles he added a towel to
like be like a marker underwater Oh tell
her I think and the second hole is like
comically huge here we go
it can't be missed by a man that's so
cool finally I'll please girlfriend ah
that's not much air up here is that all
yeah you should have went further
because he did way more than after
literally almost dying I think he got
scared Golden Retriever though yeah me
too it's more visually interesting than
he was trying to get through a small
hole
can I get one and leave them at your
house yes okay yeah oh wait like forever
for a long time doing the gold I took an
online survey to see what kind of dog I
am and it was golden retriever oh cool I
just get a Tim no and then my my my ex
who I was dating when I took the survey
which was like in high school who was
like a [ __ ] yeah she took the eggs and
guess what dog she was chihuahua what
was she Mexican not Korean oh I like
Courtney's man Corey's are [ __ ] dope
dog you should get him a cork you did
y'all don't let me jump yo they're small
but see though anyone yeah there's smart
[ __ ] too like a Clarkie that was my
dog all dog fluffy booty tooch fluffy
but I wanna I want it what about a
poodle big ones yeah it looks so like
funky and cute and their high father
died next they don't shed I'm so tired
of shedding the second smartest dog
poodles are yes [ __ ] smart reporter
calling yeah Casey wants the poodle to
be like the small Oh like ma Duke I'm
yeah oh is that like a labradoodle or is
that a poodle know what Labradoodle is
the big one and it's got more of the
squared the one that you always think I
want but I don't walk I like Labradoodle
what it was cool the only other thing I
want when you're not listening literally
every time what are those Japanese ones
that smile the [ __ ] Shiva tail
there's so greyhounds freaked me out
their whole body structures too
intimidating is a dog yeah
Dobermans are not-- - I just would never
want to like I know it does look sick in
movies but it's sad in movies it looks
so goddamn sick when you need that
moment of like oh no scary dogs coming
out of the darkness yeah yeah yeah it's
so mean yeah real life like oh man do
you have any dangerous bucket list items
dangerous no I don't want to do
dangerous things no yeah I don't want a
bungee jumps I don't want to what would
you jump out of a plane any that [ __ ] I
did a lot of dangerous [ __ ] I'm doing
what's what is it what is it what's the
most only my twenties are trying to
[ __ ] get I tried to get into
altercations all every week altercation
I mean diving that's kind of dangerous
yeah scuba you got the cuffs okay no I
was trying to get into altercations
every [ __ ] week on YouTube that [ __ ]
extreme sports wise - you're scuba
diving what inexcusable he does get into
life-threatening situations with other
humans right so because I know I think
I'm at four I'm less likely to be
interested in that [ __ ] you know what
about next time I didn't give a [ __ ] I
don't know what the [ __ ] a single
stone-headed [ __ ] so I've I've been
skydiving and I've been bungee jumping
that sounds fun it was so fun I got
wanna go skydiving again but now like
not gonna lie like after the the Kobe
[ __ ] I'm kind of like exactly in my head
it's in your head yeah in my head I'm
like I have a wife now I kind of why
would I want to put my life in danger
when I don't know it is fine it's so fun
wrong with me then cuz I've had a kid I
am married I have a lot to live for
equipment I love putting my life
Oh your design that means you can be
like certified I know well no I'll take
the back support it's the whole thing oh
I really do want to get but I think the
difference is I'm kind of like you are I
don't see it as dangerous maybe so I
just think I don't either
yeah it's it's fun fun yeah he's way
more dangerous honestly driving is way
more danger no no with the legit dude
that I think is kind of dangerous is I
would run by a pool with scissors I
think I might [ __ ] time I wouldn't even
do that oh yeah outside the pile let's
not go crazy dude sorry
our conflicts that we just moved out at
out of the the tile around the pool was
a slippery kind we're on like what the
[ __ ] I don't I think I did the most
life-threatening thing and it was
driving in Vietnam oh yeah so do you
actually draw best burgers yeah
drove in yeah
[Music]